i can't help it i just i hear that music
and i want to just start
going and we're live and it's you know
it's just exciting i get excited to see
you guys hello vff's
i get excited to be here having a job
with this crew
and doing this show that's right guys
so okay i want you to meet
the uh boyfriend i was talking about so
i got this
at the uh pumpkin patch at this weekend
the patch and yeah that was me on
saturday if you're ever like what do you
do in your off time well
that um and i just i don't know i had
the electric connection
and he was like all by himself and
i was like that's my pumpkin i know it
he's a keeper
um but i gotta tell you i discovered
that he's having a little bit of
trauma i know i'm like god no gosh
please
my boyfriend so i was just wondering are
there any pumpkin heads in the wall
today
any vffs who can help me with a pumpkin
problem
tim oh good morning drew
good morning tim how are you today i'm
great
i'm growing pumpkins up in pelham new
hampshire
well then listen pumpkin doctor i'm so
glad that you came into my
life because i'm a little worried about
my gentleman right here
do you have any advice for me well i
would say
keep that wound clean and dry um
[Laughter]
what did you say shoot sorry by the way
do you want to hear like
find out a little secret i have another
boyfriend
you you do i'm too timing this little
guy
is an ifb and he goes in my ear and
sometimes i'm actually two-timing and
having multiple voices in my head
sorry tim what did you say i said keep
the wound clean and dry
oh okay so go like like
red cross on him
i understand okay clean and dry also tim
can i ask you a question i carve
pumpkins with my kids all the time and
then within days they're all rotted at
the bottom
is there something you can do to fix
that for all of us to know
once once you carve the pumpkin um
you're looking at seven to ten days
before
you have rot so tim no one tells you
that
so we're all being let down in our
expectations thank you now we know
we have an expiration date once we put
the knife in
we tell you after you buy the pumpkin
smart tim you got a boston accent
is that what i hear yes it is um
do you know legal seafoods yes i do
do you like their clam chowder yes i do
it's my favorite
it really is my sister-in-law jill just
sent me like through gold belly
a bunch and i ate it for breakfast the
other day tim thank you so much
hello to boston hello to new hampshire
and thank you
now i know what to do all right you guys
vsf's i gotta tell you
you are really kicking it autumnal today
i am feeling it i feel this whole theme
and we have an amazingly warm show today
you